En qué consiste este acuerdo que permite
ahora para el Líbano de Israel a la hora
de la explotación de gas
un saludo Juan Muchas gracias por la
invitación este acuerdo es importante al
menos por tres razones en
primer lugar porque sientan las bases
para una mejora en la relación entre el
Líbano e Israel hay que recordar que en
el último tiempo Israel ha normalizado
relaciones con algunos de los países de
oriente medio como Marruecos bahrein
emiratos árabes pero con su círculo
inmediato Sigue estando en guerra en el
caso de Siria en el caso del Líbano
Obviamente con Palestina Entonces lo
primero es que se halla en el camino
para una paz futura con el Líbano en
segundo lugar esto le permitirá
seguramente al Líbano acceder a recursos
porque la situación económica es muy
compleja en el último tiempo y estamos
hablando de dos Campos en Cádiz y en
Canadá con ingentes recursos
especialmente en gas y En tercer lugar
aclarar que esto no implica un
reconocimiento diplomático de el Líbano
a Israel es decir siguen estando en
guerra Aunque
hay un avance hacia la normalización que
deberá ocurrir en algún momento de la
historia cree usted que el actual
coyuntura económica en la que vivimos
con una espirales inflacionista ha
forzado ha tenido algo que ver para que
se llegara esta rúbrica particularmente
como usted menciona en el caso del
Líbano que vive una profunda crisis
financiera y que busca un alivio con
este acuerdo
sin duda alguna
incluso antes de la
No ya venía en una crisis financiera
tremenda al Estado está básicamente en
bancarrota hay una devaluación de la
moneda que los diferentes gobiernos no
han podido detener hay una escasez de
combustible en algún momento dado se
habló
por la intercesión de hezbolá que Irán
le entregara combustible a al Líbano
entonces hay una situación de
desabastecimiento hay un déficit enorme
y obviamente los dos años de parálisis
producto del covid terminaron por aún a
ahondar aún más la crisis libanesa que
insisto es una crisis que tiene unos
rasgos económicos insisto por la
bancarrota del estado de libanés pero
también hay una crisis política muy
grande acordémonos de la expresión la
explosión en el puerto de beirut y que
todavía no se han establecido
responsabilidades ha habido algunos
amagos de violencia intercomunitaria
entonces sin duda alguna el acuerdo
llega para aliviar primero la situación
económica que es muy delicada y
eventualmente en un futuro corto con
ayudar en la estabilización política del
Líbano